sport et culture vont nous occuper
durant les prochaines minutes de cette
édition culture avec le concert voie en
scène proposé à Mani Lamo le 25 mai
bonsoir audre brouan vous êtes coach
vocal responsable de cette association
organisme de formation on va parler du
concert donc du 25 mai tout à l'heure et
puis du du sport également avec Didier
BS bonsoir vous êtes membre de l'équipe
de kayak polo de trappe Saint-Quentin on
commence avec vous le 26 mai à la base
de l' à saquentin 4e journée du
championnat de France de National 4 vous
allez disputer ce match au poste de
gardien oui comment se joue le kayak
polo bah c'est c'est un sport jeune déjà
et bon c'est un sport
d'équipe deux équipes de cinq joueurs
donc un gardien et ça s'apparente
beaucoup au
handball basketball water poo euh voilà
mais c'est très physique intense c'est
assez physique oui bon un joueur par
exemple n'a pas le droit de conserver la
balle plus de 5 secondes c'est ça ou
donc dès que vous l'avez il faut la
renvoyer la balle ouais ou vous pouvez
la conserver mais on la jetant euh
devant vous enfin en l'éloignant de
votre bateau vous vous êtes lancé à quel
moment dans cette dans cette pratique de
ce sport vous l'avez découvert comment
aussi bah moi je l'ai découvert quand je
me suis inscrit en fait au club euh je
connaissais pas avant de canoé qui
propose notamment donc cette cette
branche kayak polo voà cette spécialité
et donc voilà j'ai découvert ça comme ça
et ça m'a plu je m'amuse bien et c'est
un sport bien évidemment collectif on a
vu quelques images si vous voulez
découvrir la façon dont ça se déroule
rendez-vous à la base de loisir le
weekend du 26 mai vous allez affronter
combien d'équipes sur ce sur cette
journée euh trois je crois trois équipes
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne pour
cette formule de championnat de de
national 4 he oui en général oui c'est
trois trois ou quatre matchs par par
réunion en fait alors quelles sont les
chances de votre équipe vous êtes
actuellement avantdernier sur la zone
nord-ouest ouais effectivement
malheureusement euh bon bah il y a il y
a un manque de réussite malgré que c'est
un championnat qui est à part vraiment
ceux qui sont dans le haut du tableau
euh où là la différence de niveau est
importante bon autreemment c'est assez
équilibré bon on a un petit manque de
réussite bon ça se joue des fois à pas
grand-chose voilà bon la rencontre est
organisée dans le cadre de la Fête du
Nautisme le club donc de trappe
Saint-Quentin de canoué qui proposera
d'autres animations tout au long de la
jour jné le public pourra s'essayer
aussi à ce kayak polo oui tout à fait
euh samedi à partir de 14h il y a une
une initiation le dimanche le match et
le samedi la possibilité de voilà le
samedi et le le dimanche il y aura la la
compétition le kayak polo c'est une
pratique qui se développe aussi est-ce
qu'il y a de plus en plus de monde qui
s'y intéresse 85 c'est 1985 un premier
championnat national en France 1980 la
France met en place une équipe nationale
donc vous le disiez tout à l'heure c'est
un sport jeune ouais c'est un sport
assez jeune oui alors au niveau des des
demandes est-ce qu'il y beaucp ça c'est
variable suivant les les saisons on a
plus ou moins de demandes bon maintenant
au niveau
national je ne sais pas trop si si ça
fait plus desmul mais bon on essaie de
de promouvoir vous n disiez vous vous
l'avez découvert par
hasard au club aujourd'hui pour vous
c'est jamais sans mon kayak partout dès
que vous partez en vacances vous repérez
des des lieux des endroits pour le
pratiquer par que c'est une vraie
passion enfin bah passion euh oui et non
enfin bon on s'accorde quand même un peu
de repos à l'occasion de de congé bon un
sport physique c'est un sport qui coûte
cher à pratiquer aussi peut-être parce
qu'il faut sûr non en fait bon on a des
sorties là actuellement on est sur la
zone nord-ouest donc on va jusqu'en
Bretagne bon ça nous coûte c'est au prix
coûtant en fait voilà les frais les les
frais engagés carburant dépl combien ça
coûte de s'équiper aussi d'avoir son
kayak d'avir la tenue le club le club
fournit euh le matériel en général après
c'est du bon c'est c'est quoi maillot de
bain des petits maillots le reste gilet
casque et cetera est fourni par le par
le club le bateau aussi on en revient à
cette compétition 4e journée de
Nationale 4 quelles sont les ambitions
de l'équipe alors combien de de matchs
il reste à jouer bah là je pense que
pour nous c'est la dernière journée
parce que après on passe dans les
demi-finale et je pense qu'on sera pas
là donc peut-être remonter d'une
place si tout se passe bien maintenant
voilà vous NZ pas de descendre bah si
donc un petit peu d' jeu sur cette cette
dernière journée C TR match que bon il
va nous manquer deux trois
joueurs qui vont qui vont nous manquer
vraiment bon alors venez encourager
cette équipe de trae Saint-Quentin en
yeline en kayak polo 26 mai de 9h30 à
17h à la base de loisir alors bien sûr
il y a des interruptions il y a trois
trois rencontres hein vous n'allez pas
jouer nonstop entre 9h30 et 17h on vous
le souhaite sinon ce sera effectivement
peut-être un petit peu compliqué il y a
un site internet aussi pour ceux qui
veulent en savoir plus et pratiquer
peut-être tout simplement le le canoé
pas forcément le kayak polo puisque le
le club de trap Saint-Quentin propose de
nombreuses activités merci à vous